this morning is Elon Musk meeting
generalize session which is sort of like
a big buzz confidence Jen it's like a
big event but a lot of that is really a
huge amount that we have on our schedule
so I think we might try and go to the
Academy of Sciences this afternoon
and do sort of touristy afternoon most
of all science stuff is now on Wednesday
and Thursday those are two big days so
kind of taking it easy up until ahem I
guess right I'm supposed to fight all
there's the key
yeah it turns out a lot of people want
to go see Elon Musk who'd have thought
it
okay so we're in the cube we're now in a
cube so big it has meanders if his face
went under is going to end up with an
oxbow lake I think I've been in a queue
this big maybe when I was at the Kings
workshop convention 2006 just a boy
the room was cute I reckon about 2,000
people will see you might be
disappointing yeah the rest of accuse of
stretching often that they're up into
the distance and that middle third
we're part of the UK is Exeter the
southwest bit where everyone picks like
pirates I think this must be what it's
like to feel like Apple all these people
individuals we are not like we made so
that was bad we just thought you're must
talk we're now in the exhibition hall
just having free stopping yeah but that
was by interesting I mean it's you know
you basically go to these tours because
they've got a very big name associated
with Anil musk is one of the biggest
names in tech
I didn't think much of the questions
that were prepared by the president of
the Asian you have questions and the
audience were interesting and they
weren't all so basically yeah just so
gratifying him which was basically what
the previous questions were but it's
interesting to him I think the quote of
the session was rockets a tough if only
gravity was a little bit less yeah
engaging guy I can see why he gets
following too and now we're just nabbing
all the free stuff we find casually
there's just the Tesla Roadster lying
around because Elon Musk's in town so I
just bailed on the exhibit hall which is
basically I realized like a company's
version of fresh is back and I hate
fresh back so I'm not gonna go to the
student lounge account mr. Otherworld I
was doing yesterday
hopefully snare some free food in the
process and yeah this afternoon I'm not
quite sure what we're doing yeah
we might not be going to the Academy of
Sciences I don't think there's enough
time we did not Friday there's a party
going on the Career Center in Suitland
blow your help she researches the role
the short-lived Climate Pollutants lay
in okay so I went to a session on the
science science communication which is
really using plane on those very well
constructed session like the first
speaker was all about using plain
English the second speaker is all about
telling a story and the third speaker is
all about using infographics and they're
like the three key components to science
communication I think a little bit
uneven in terms of the quality but it
was really good session I think it's
really important these conferences do
those kind of sessions
I think might not been exactly the
target audience but I still focus on me
come on
thank you I think I still like a few
things so I think gets much now okay so
it turns out the lady with the Darth
Vader s chain I'm a fan over there is in
fact Margaret liner who's the president
of age year we're really sorry hello and
welcome to the next installment of Simon
talked into a camera will walk you
through a conference
so I just did a little bit of work and
my work I mean kind of just catching up
on emails and watching YouTube videos in
the student lounge we're now a free food
and drink
FIO times a day which is good Tom just
bought a poster tube from the exhibit
hall but it turns out it's a seismic and
turning it and now we're going to the
session which we just found out which is
all about social media in academia
there's two sessions one after the other
given that I'm doing this right now
she's about ready for it
is it telescopic yes ah let's telescopic
so tongue as it turned out ever had the
right postage tube is telescopic and now
I have one as well and which was
basically the last one in the entire
conference
so Thomas incredibly good cool for me to
get it right now that's take me a lot of
boy talk about
we just went to a social media session
which was interesting it was mostly
about blogging rather than for logging
so there's slightly different my
expertise but very interesting getting
people's takes on looking at covering
things like climate change and dealing
with patrollers comment dealing with
like tying in with institutions two
hours of that and then I just went to
dinner with a lovely lady Laura from the
EGU we actually had a drink in dinner as
we both these week so we just thought
we'd combine business with eating which
is great and we went to this really cool
bar somewhere just people like a block
from the conference center and
apparently I had the best mac and cheese
that the server had ever seen quite on
really considering those over and I
can't talk about what we talked about
there's a little bit hush-hush and
totally agreed yet but he might be
seeing me doing suddenly the eg you
possibly may be in more than one
sessions can't say more than that pretty
much said already but yeah
now that layer between ten kilometers
and fifty comms announced you is what we
call a stratosphere and it accounts for
almost the entirety of the remaining
mass of the atmosphere see ya let's see
if I can remember this or if you want
more videos with John not just talking
about stuff then please comment below
make sure you go and look at that
singing playlist of choral music about
Christmas comment below with which what
piece is your favorite you know just
have a listen to a few on shuffle